foreign
almost all of the people that reach out
to our show are facing boundary issues
with their in-laws or facing a husband
who's hasn't hit them yet but it's
abusive right or they're staring at
their seven-year-old and their 14 year
old they don't know what to do right or
the two-year-old and three-year-old yeah
or their sex life falling apart and they
don't know how to have a conversation
about what happens next yeah what you
have emerged like like almost overnight
which we all know is a Decades of
practice right is like really a
world-class
teacher on
hey say it like this instead of like
this and it's it's so counter-cultural
that it's and it's such a gift to people
and you've got a clear way and I'm
always telling the folks who who watch
the show if you get pissed off at your
wife or husband there's nothing wrong
with you right you probably got a
generation of wiring and genetics and
the way you your parents treated you
like you've got all these things well
you don't have a set of skills or set of
tools correct and so I thought this
would be awesome to run some scenarios
by you and you can teach me assistant
this is not my family because I'm
perfect this is clearly for everybody
right right right right so a person X
grows up in a home whose mom was real
domineering dad was real quiet just hid
behind a newspaper by his behind his
iPad and there's this inner rage that
happens then your wife comes home 20
years later and that same story just
kicks up again right yeah so husband
gets home he drives up the driveway
wreck real fast dinner was at six they
had just had like a a marriage Retreat a
few months before where he was gonna
work really hard on being on time
because it she felt his wife felt
disrespected right he drives up he's 45
minutes late
and he's already preparing the story
right and he was at work but he's also
just kind of scrolling on crap and
joking around and laughing or whatever
and he actually feels bad that he's late
but then he also feels pissed that she's
going to get mad that he was late
because I've been working so hard and I
can't just spend 15 freaking minutes
talking to my buddies right yeah so he
walks in the two kids are there already
halfway through the meal and then he
gets that mix of anger and shame like I
should be here with my family and how
dare they start without me it happens at
the same time yeah right
and he looks at her and she just has
that look like
I thought things gonna be different and
he launches into a story dude I was
walking out the door and then so and so
came by clearly making this up yeah and
she knows he's lying and she's at a
Breaking Point and she thinks I got him
and suddenly we're at a proxy war over
here and we're fighting about you lied
and you uh never tell the truth like
this whole thing happens yeah what are
some ways that a she can defuse that
situation yeah and B actually get to a
place of where we can interact right
it's a hard spot to be you find yourself
on the same Battlefield that you felt
like you were you had already won yeah
you know you have this kind of this
one-on-one that's hey we have this
meeting of the minds we had an
understanding and then something happens
and you fall back into ordinary life and
all of a sudden you realize
we don't even know each other again it's
almost into betrayal very much so in
this the sense of I thought we had a
pact I thought we had a baseline
connection and all of a sudden you
realize that connection is is broken
like in a like a light switch Yeah if
you're gonna have a light on there's
that circuitry that connects them
but if it's switched off then it's then
it's broken then then it's dark and then
you're going I can't see where are you
where am I and you have that sense of
I'm just feeling around and and that's
scary for both people and if I'm sitting
in that room you know at a thousand foot
View and I'm looking at this family that
is going through the same thing both of
our family everybody's family yeah I
mean I can anybody can relate to that
um what comes to mind is three things
one you can't have that conversation in
front of the kids I believe you're in a
similar mindset of there are certain
things you talk about in front of your
kids and certain things you you don't
because and from what I recall I mean
growing up if my parents got in an
argument
I thought my life was over you know what
I mean like like if they were in an
argument
I mean even with my kids if my wife and
I are
just doing something easy they're like
what's what's happening yeah yeah that
shakes them they don't need that second
of all is there is a power and timing
and a power and discernment and knowing
when to have that conversation so you
know it's not then and then you know
it's later this guy's coming in she
already knows that he's late he knows
what he did wrong is there's no question
right and so whenever he comes in she
has a choice at that moment
do I become the attacker
or do I choose later in that moment
to have a conversation to connect again
to see if this is something he's willing
to fix and you have it's hard man very
hard yeah because I want to hit him
there's nothing easy about it but but
you play it out you play it out that
what's she gonna do she stands up oh
really you're going to be late oh okay
yeah I guess it's gonna be cold uh go
ahead and do it in the microwave hi kids
guess dad didn't want to come home for
dinner you go I mean and there it's off
and then all of a sudden you are the bad
one yeah you you've already ruined it
and if somebody is a scolded dog coming
in there's no use
kicking them right then I mean they
already know and so what I would tell
that Mom
is you enjoy time with your kids you
finish dinner you let's let's do bath
time let's let's say prayers let's get
them in bed and then you come back and
sit down
and say how was your day
man that's the flex of like you saying
that even makes me go yeah yeah but
imagine
but imagine the the
strength that you would also show oh
yeah when you sit back and you go
how's your day I mean that husband's
going it's a power vacuum right yeah can
you just please yell at me yeah yeah can
you yell at me like I already know what
I did wrong can you can we just what's
up with you yeah but that ability to sit
back and
um have that bird's eye view of I can
I become more confident and I become
stronger
the less that I put out I mean in the
scenarios I give is it's very much if I
add ice cubes to the water
or you know ice cubes of the drink you
deluded and many times we add way too
many ice cubes we want to start off
being angry we want to start off saying
all the wrong things and when it's
concentrated
it's it's you're much more potent it's
it's not easy I also think you give
somebody
well two things I'm gonna touch on one
there's been some kind of some turning
in the psychological literature of the
last decade or so about
um
it's really important actually to have
some level of disagreement in front of
your kids because there's a generation
taught go fight in the back bedroom yeah
and what you ended up with a group a
generation of young people that started
you know having getting married and then
they'd have their first big fight and
they hadn't had no reference point right
oh this is over yeah we're breaking up
we're getting divorced we've only been
married nine months but there's also
you liar you like that she's ready to
like come full force don't do that in
front yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and and
so the husband comes in and what he's
wanting to do when he starts and he's
already got a story he's going right so
what he's wanting to do is control that
narrative before she even has it out
you'll see that a lot and you have a
disagreement with somebody they want to
they'll back up and back up and they'll
say okay I came in and when I came in
you did this and then that made me say
this that made me say this right and so
they then become a character in their
story ah and that's what they're doing
they've become they've become the author
and the lead yeah you know and and the
victim all in one and that's where you
have the chance to continue to pull
apart if if they're really invested in
fixing that and owning that I mean
because you're catching them in a lie
essentially is what you're doing it but
there's also a moment where if you're
truly invested and this is hard man
especially if you've been in an abusive
relationship over time if you're truly
invested in healing
there is a chance
that
at 4 48 as he was getting ready to leave
his boss came in and said I have to have
this before you walk out the door right
and no text could have that happen
um even though y'all had said hey if
you're gonna be late just shoot me a
text like the whole thing just
Avalanches on you and you get upset you
get frustrated that approach does give
an Avenue for Humanity that's right for
me to say give it a chance no really
I was texting and driving because I was
trying to catch my wife at the hospital
I wasn't just this out of control yeah
right yeah so there's some there's some
Humanity there and also man it just
vacuums power oh yeah yeah you become
you become the most credible
in the room yeah when that happens yeah
and so a lot of the times you know as as
an attorney I might have somebody who
makes a snide comment in the courtroom
and one of my favorite moves is let's
say let's say you would we're at let's
say we're at a deposition right now
you're on the other side and I'm
cross-examining you just like Dustin
kind of did you said something like hey
all you all you attorneys are the worst
you know what you're the worst thing
that could happen in this Society
my favorite move
is for me to just kind of take it in and
go well
maybe so
that right there is just that little
maybe so okay
I give them nothing in return I dropped
their words off a cliff they go but but
you were supposed to catch that yeah I
said I oh it's on the floor yeah yeah
they're like no no you you were supposed
to catch that and throw it back at me I
said no I don't it's it's in the trash
I'm not gonna I'm gonna go pick that
back up and so it's that that that
thought of you are completely within
your own control of how defensive you
get so if you cannot measure your
reaction then you measure your response
and you do that in a way that
always puts you as the most credible the
most confident in the room but what a
power flexed every time because it's
they're expecting me to say oh really
we're the worst in in the world what
about you yeah yeah that's exactly right
yeah me what about you yeah this class
it's like a kid coming up and hitting an
adult as hard as they can and just not
moving yeah and the kids like that's all
I got yeah right I mean it's such a yeah
I'm not going to push you back I don't
have to right you're not gonna react oh
that's even worse okay what you've given
us is
I think one of the most important and
poignant and hardest lessons in human
relationships which is nobody can truly
make you do anything and man that's hard
to learn yeah